The other shoe dropped for
me then because you know,
you're,
you're talking about
that at least in part,
you're talking about that
ecstatic experience as the,
as the necessary counter position
to isolation and abandonment,
loneliness and all of those things,
which,
which I think is a very,
a very reasonable way
of thinking about it.
It's like meaning as the antidote
to isolation and Tra and tragedy and
malevolence for that matter.
And I think music is,
you know,
I've thought deeply about music.
I've,
I've tried to figure out why it has,
what it represents and why it
has the effects that it has.
And I think,
and this is a neuroscientific
few of it to some degree,
and you know,
it seems to me that it's better to think
about the world as con as something
that consists of patterns rather than
as something that consists of objects.
So it object would actually be a pattern
that sustains itself across time.
It's it,
that's not all that very,
very good insight.
You get applause for that.
Thank you.
And so,
so then you think,
well for you,
you can even think about the way
the visual system works this way.
So you know,
we tend to think that there's a world
out there and then there's an image of
that world projected onto our retina
and then the images is reconstructed,
say in our visual cortex.
And then we,
uh,
then we can become conscious of
that image and planner actions in,
in a,
in consequence of that.
But that isn't how it works.
The way it works is that
there are patterns in the
world and then the patterns
are shifted into patterns
of light of illumination.
And then those are shifted into patterns
of neural activity on the retina.
And then those are shifted into
patterns of neural conductance,
the law,
the optical nerves,
and then patterns in the visual cortex.
And then those are expressed
as patterns of movement.
So it's all the transformations of
patterns and the meaning of a visual
perception is the pattern of
action that it gives rise to,
which is why you need a body
meant to be able to perceive.
And I think the reason that music speaks
so deeply to us of fundamental meaning
is because it's actually the
most representative art form.
You know,
because people think
about it in some senses,
the least representative art form,
I don't think that's right at all.
I think it represents the reality that
exists in a profound sense beyond what
our census revealed to
us moment to moment.
And so it puts people then when you're
moving to the music and we were all
moving to the music,
or when you're dancing,
let's say with someone else and you're,
and you're as pairs and
you're all dancing together,
it's that the patterns of the cosmos,
so to speak,
manifesting themselves as the patterns
of the music manifesting themselves as
the patterns of your body and in
syncopation with everyone else.
So it's also a symbolic
representation of a harmonious,
an ideal society.
And there it is something
that's beyond us.
And so it's,
it's interests.
So I get it.
So,
so partly what you're saying,
if I understand you,
is that for you,
the,
the ecstatic collective that
was associated with music,
for example,
in pop music perhaps was you could see
it out very clearly as the antidote to
painful isolation.
And,
and I mean,
one of the things that struck me as,
as,
as struck me as near
miraculous about music,
especially in the rather
nihilistic and atheistic society,
is that it really does fill the void
that was left by the death of God.
And it's partly because you
cannot rationally critique music.
You know,
it speaks to you,
it speaks of meaning.
And no matter what you say about it,
no matter how cynical you are,
you cannot put a crowbar
underneath that and lifted up and,
and,
and toss it aside.
And music was so,
such a powerful cultural force in
the 60s and the 70s and it's like
overwhelmingly powerful force.